factorizar 40 sea el cubo menos 5 d al
cubo quizás lo primero que te viene a la
mente es ver que ambos términos tienen
un 5 en común entonces vamos a
factorizar ese 5 déjame reescribir
primero este 40 s al cubo como 5 por 8
11 al cubo y luego restamos 5 por d al
cubo entonces podemos factorizar el 5 de
ambos términos y obtenemos obtenemos 5
por 8 c al cubo menos de al cubo de algo
simplemente estamos aprovechando la ley
distributiva pero al revés estamos
distribuyendo vale bueno ahora nos queda
esta expresión y a lo mejor puedas ver
que esto de aquí es un cubo 8 es un cubo
sea el cubo es un cubo entonces esto de
aquí es 2 c
entonces déjame reescribir esta
expresión ahora en términos de cubos de
la siguiente manera esto es igual a 5
por 2 c2c al cubo menos de al cubo y
entonces tenemos una diferencia de cubos
y resulta que las diferencias de cubos
se pueden factorizar con unos ciertos
patrones son unas ciertas fórmulas que
puede ser que conozcas o no pero si no
las conoces pues mejor aún porque
ahorita puedes aprender las entonces si
tienes una diferencia de cubos se puede
factorizar de la siguiente manera al
cubo menos b al cubo es igual a menos b
por a cuadrada más a b más b cuadrada y
también tenemos una fórmula similar para
sumar de cubos me voy a poner con este
color amarillo que dice que a al cubo
más b al cubo es igual a a más ve a más
b el paréntesis base acá
por cuadrada menos ave más cuadrada
entonces esta segunda ahorita no nos va
a servir pero es muy útil utilizar estas
dos fórmulas en algunos problemas
ahorita vamos a utilizar la primera y si
no sabes a qué se debe pues te
recomiendo que multiplicas estos
términos de la derecha muchas cosas se
van a cancelar y finalmente vas a acabar
con esto misma idea aquí abajo e incluso
puedes jugar para ver si puedes deducir
una a partir de la otra pero bueno
ahorita vamos a aplicar directamente la
fórmula de aquí arriba y quién sería que
pues a ver tenemos un primer término al
cubo y ese se llama a así que este
término que voy a marcar en rojo sería a
déjame escribir lo voy a poner que a es
igual a 2 c y este segundo término está
de que voy a marcar en color rosa esté
acá va a ser se va a ser b va a ser b
vale entonces b va a ser igual a d muy
bien entonces a es 12 veces igual a de
tenemos al cubo menos b al cubo
vamos a factorizar lo entonces tenemos
que esto es igual a 5 ese 5 es el 5 que
ya estaba x tenemos que poner a menos b
entonces a es 12 vamos a poner 12 - b
que es de menos de menos de y eso
tenemos que multiplicarlo multiplicarlo
por a cuadrada entonces vamos a hacer al
cuadrada aquí tenemos a déjame poner al
cuadrado aquí a cuadrada es igual a 2 al
cuadrado que es igual a 4 c al cuadrado
entonces es cuadrada que es 4 c al
cuadrado luego va más a por b más 2 c
por b que es d
por de más de cuadrada o sea de cuadras
más de cuadras simplemente estamos
usando esta fórmula para ello ha
igualado se ve igual a de muy bien
déjame nada más reescribir esto para que
se vea un poco más bonito esto queda
igual a 5 x 2 c menos de x 4 se cuadrada
más 2 cede más de cuadrada y listo con
esto terminamos de factorizar la
expresión 40 sea el cubo menos 5 de al
cubo